shihri il ya deux ou trois séquences qui
ont posé un petit peu problème milliards
dans l'amour est dans le pré
on a vu donc le thomas un agriculteur
évoqué son homosexualité auprès de
karine le marchand
regardez cet extrait c'est la première
apparition de taux promo assez jeune
mais je n'ai pas compris en fait alors
tu fais comme tout le monde mais après
tu t'aperçois que tu es patois du
pouvoir et là ça commence à être dur
[Musique]
ces moments c'est plus compliqué parce
que du coup tu affrontes un peu de la
société en dix ans
c'est comme ça
fait du jour où tu tu acceptes en fait
ça va mieux
enfin penser que cette folle annoncé
ouais ouais c'est des choses pas
évidente à dire surtout à la ta famille
après j'ai pas eu de vraie difficulté
avec mes parents parce qu'ils ont quand
même été
[Musique]
ouais c'est cool avec ça alors les
magnifiques et allons marquer mais que
je fais très bien alerte daverton
urgences devraient pas ce que je veux
montrer la séquence qui a fait le plus
parler ghana 2 1
la première c'est karine qui a fait
voilà qui a parlé de la culture gay qui
n'est pas très bien passé sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce que vous en pensez regardez ça ça
fait beaucoup réagir ses victoires ouais
je pense enfin j'espère un coup de barre
et ouais ouais ouais ouais ne doute pas
c'est qu'il ya un nom pour sa rigueur
les jags szeged en bref c'est l'ailier
qui se reconnaissent pas la langue dans
tout ce qui est chez les b culture gay
mais farmer madonna dalida
ça c'est non non en l'air ça s'appelle
le yagg
ah ouais je sais une fois voilà merci à
toi je te re appris un truc non pas de
mèche basse bicolore insurgée michela
deuxième séquence qui a posé problème
après franchement dit la vérité
lorsqu'elle est ce que ça fait ce
problème à quelqu'un parce que sur
twitter ça beaucoup beaucoup fait parler
un conte ce problème est oui alors vous
personne ça le prénom c'est pas tant que
ça pose problème mais c'est qu'on a
l'impression d'être dans tellement vrai
ou c'est mon choix pas pour moi ça n'a
rien à faire dans l'amour est dans le
pré où j'ai ma cellule c'est très
émouvant c'était marrant c'était
larmoyant la mésaventure ukrainienne par
exemple mais pour moi c'est pas l'amour
est dans le pré c'est un morceau de deux
heures quinze secondes de deux heures on
peut pas juger mission là dessus pour
moi et en faire au national à quelque
chose c'est que ce n'était pas
nécessaire
c'est dé découvrir les agriculteurs
après que quelle analyse quelque chose
qu'elle fait partie du projet mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé serguey non
non mais où et comment c'est à dire que
c'est ce que c'est les yaks décidé
d'apprendre quelque chose à un gay oui
j'ai envie que ça y est ce que selon lui
il a pas l'air de connaître ça moi
personnellement je suis pas bon non plus
elle affirme quelque chose je sais pas
du tout ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ça
deviens fou dans le portrait mais si
vous attendez mon chéri non j'écoutais
ou du canard je n'ai jamais quand je te
regarde
non le problème c'est pas ça c'est que
d'abord moisson de débit l'intérieur de
pathos ce côté vert raconte moi comment
tu t'es accepté là c'est du mauvais
sophie davant l'après midi
qui parle en 8es à tous non je donne mon
avis parce que c'est pas le vôtre qu'il
faut me dire ce moment et après après ce
qui m'agace un petit peu effectivement
c'est le côté tu ne te retrouves pas
dans la culture gay mylène farmer dan
richards sais pas quoi risque ici se
passe là bas rien mais c'est vrai que là
pour le coup alors fini les clichés
comme me fallait au moins ça le serait
fiché mais elle est là il ya un nombre
de clichés incroyable ils vont se marier
pendant la pub parce que j'habite tous
et chantonnay bateau terralia que c'est
sûr parce qu'ici les gaines mylène
farmer
savez-vous j'allais aussi ce qu'il faut
se rendre compte c'est que l surtout pas
de l'orgueil elle s'est seulement de les
mettre à l'aise voilà ce qu'il y à des
confidences ils sont pas faciles à dire
ce que les agriculteurs sous un peu
taiseux un peu pudique elle essaie avec
des petites blagues star décide alors de
le voir faire accoucher cela la personne
qui recherche sait et il fait exactement
chose dans ce cas qu'un astéroïde monde
qu'est ce que tu recherches comme c est
ce que c'est une photo avec des colliers
de perles et très ou plutôt une fille un
peu sport isda il ferait les choses
progressent j'arrête là
[Applaudissements]